[Music]
in Asian parenting news oh boy
submitted by the wasteland a father made
his ten-year-old son beg for food at a
train station to teach him a lesson
oh yeah I know I like it yep you like it
it's China yeah so in Shanghai
police responded to an emergency call
about a boy with a school bag on his
knees begging for food at the train
station and so when they got there and
they found this ten-year-old little boy
he was holding a small bowl and then
asking people for food can I guess what
happened could I guess why he got
punished yeah did he waste food and like
he didn't finish his food and then the
dad was like there's people that are
starving you should know what he's
starving do it's a bit for food that
would make more sense
oh yeah any more guesses you cheated on
Chinese checkers oh he got an a-minus
you're getting warmer okay he skipped
school no no D cheat on American
checkers no so what happened was he this
kid didn't finish his homework oh oh so
the hell so the logic is you're you're
not gonna get a job and this is how
you're not exactly so by the time the
the police officers got there the little
boy said his father had left him at the
station about 45 minutes earlier and so
that's when the cops took him in and oh
and so the kid also told the cops that
he was reported by his teacher that he
didn't finish his homework and so his
father told him to kneel and beg for
food as punishment so that's when the
cops took him in to the police station
where they gave him some biscuits and a
hot drink and then contacted his mother
who then picked picked him up about an
hour later where I'm like why the [ __ ]
is it taking you an hour cuz the mom was
like you fed him
because pottery and so then when she
showed up she told police that her
husband was very upset because their son
was often reported for not doing his
homework and then that's when he decided
he to have him beg for food to show him
what a joyless life he will have if he
does not study hard but she did add that
she didn't agree with his method of
didn't do [ __ ] to stop him though what I
love about this is that literally on the
other side of the world from us the same
[ __ ] parenting methods that we all
went through or at least in my family
like Mike [ __ ] grandpa caught my
uncle smoking a cigar or a cigarette and
he bought him a [ __ ] cigar bulb and
he put his his military helmet on his
head and put the blast shield down and
made him [ __ ] smoke it in a helmet
yeah and then my uncle never smoked
anything ever again effective because it
made him so sick yeah but I mean that's
the city make us smoke the whole cigar
yeah the whole thing how do you not like
pass out yeah I you buy threw up or
something mention yeah get the finish
the think a picture I'm looking like
Pinocchio one of my other uncle threw up
on his carpet and he gave him a spoon
and made him eat the floor oh that's a
bit extreme that's why your agent geez
eating throw up with the spoon up the
carpet yeah basically the moral is like
get it on the tile or [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] my carpet get on the tile next
time get in the sick next time yeah
control enough to get there like how do
I teach my cat this true me [ __ ] cat
no right they find the carpet I've given
my cat so many spoons after and they
don't even do it I dropped some
look like I have smooth all over
upstairs then we [ __ ] get the lesson
but the cat throw up is still there
gives you up again yes well that's the
that's the lesson I can't take a lesson
from them that's why you don't clean it
up I do all the time but I'm not whipped
another conversation who said that
nobody camera before we were certain
some 1/2 hours ago still in his head
well fill me in I was studying for the
rest of the article that's it let me
fill you in
wu-tang [ __ ] it's close its
close native whip stain live tank
alright so anyway back to this
authorities did not take any action
against the tiger father but they did
warn the mother that these type of
punishments will damage selfish
their kids self-esteem and disrupt
public order Wow oh yeah that's
progressive or if they're probably just
saying if you're gonna do these quietly
yeah exactly yeah you're ruining all
these people these working people have
told ya don't get caught yeah punishment
it's like my grandpa saw this and he's
like that's not the Wu Tang Seng symbol
now you need to draw it 1000 times
correctly and I'd like yeah because it
cuz it kind of looks more like chores or
anything like Charizard ya see that so I
want to punish myself for it I'm gonna
draw a volcano you raised by your dad
and you wish you were raised by your
grandpa you like he like he likes
punishments I think that's why he likes
being with me oh he was the dominant one
no he is in bed oh you know but in like
regular life I'm like you didn't see my
cat's back a throat pull the spoon just
cuz your love language service and I do
things to make you happy I mean I should
be punished talking about access service
okay we're talking about I'm talking
about like who you like when I you like
being yelled at you know I don't like
being
are you talking about I tell you all the
time stop yelling at me and [ __ ] that's
how you be nicer to me actually the
other day it was like yo just be nicer
to me if I could mean to me sometimes
it's random because eating cereal here's
the other across the table no it was
like we were we have like a little
scuffle and then I was just like you
gotta be nicer to me sometimes man cuz
she's [ __ ] mean he liked it guys are
just like you just be nice a little bit
dude I'm so nice as [ __ ] oh you let this
chick I don't [ __ ] talk she knows is
gonna start this a lot compliment this
chick all the time I take it back wiping
yellow I get back what do I get back I
hear all those things oh that was a joke
can't be on the ice man can't be on a
band I mean you make her cry all the
time though so that's one I've seen it
multiple times you don't back off thank
you cried spits that he brings in truth
with disorder oh no I need you double
down okay this is what happens jail free
cards he's about to pull it right I
don't make myself cry you make me cry
you still want to jump in
you want you want part is party they
called Iceman do you want part of this
party will I'm just saying they call
nice so he doesn't want to go in this
party okay so I'm so good I'm saying
they call my old I found a different way
to double down cuz it's a miracle that
he still has away my dad did something
similar when I was in fifth grade you
know everyone's kind of like into like
pencil boxes and like mechanical pencils
and erasers and [ __ ] oh yeah and then so
like before my dad's gonna take me cuz
you know Ellie some once or twice a week
is Brett they're divorced
well they told me he's gonna take me to
McDonald's also can we stop by CVS first
which is say Vaughn's back down
yeah [ __ ] I forgot about that yeah I got
and I stole all kinds of like mechanical
pencils and erasers and stuff in my
pocket like dolls you like wait can we
make a pit stop real quick yeah yeah I
see a Jackson [ __ ] 10th grade 10th pick
me and then uh well cuz that's what
everyone at school had had some and then
so I went to McDonald's I'm a dad I'm
gonna take a piss first I don't know how
he always has like these Sherlock Holmes
things he just knows I'm up to no good
he probably dated himself maybe probably
yeah because what kid wants to go to
save ons like yeah or maybe I'm there's
a lot of plastic making noise in my
pants yeah but I walk you to the
bathroom and I'm starting to take all
the things apart so I could take all the
stuff out of the the packaging my dad
comes in and goes what the [ __ ] is that
he starts beating my ass there and he
goes I'm taking you back to save lines
and let them know that you stole from
them well bathroom in McDonald the
McDonald's so we didn't get my yummy
McDonald's and so you took me all the
way back to say Vaughn's and then he
tells them to call the cops on me cuz
I'm a thief I'm like wait this could
stop here and then I'll just say I'm
sorry and I'm not gonna do to do this
again but like I guess like the would
you have stopped his parenting style I
don't know but his parenting style was
like let's flip it a hundred percent
around you even stop after you call the
police well yeah that's how would you
handle take them in if you caught him
doing that alright hey I know that itch
want you to see a Jackson [ __ ] but I
might how about this you tell me you're
gonna go Jackson [ __ ]
I'll stay 30 feet behind you when you
jack some [ __ ] and you leave tell me
what you Jack don't go pay the register
was that is the most horrible lesson I
solve is it's because you know someone
paid for it he's like hey Dad I just saw
[Laughter]
[Music]
you from from thievery or maybe if I had
actually actually if I had an open
relationship with my parents
and if I could have requested things
that I wanted to buy cuz I think I just
wanted those things you're like no
matter what I'm getting it yeah so I
think like if we had an open
relationship and I was able to even
bring up stuff that I like so I could be
like the Joneses I think that would've
been cool so maybe I if I had an open
relation between it's like are you dad
can you buy me this half that everyone
else has oh yeah sure
every time you say I would only ship I
just as I have it operated with my son I
[Laughter]
watch him play with other kids and he
watches me playing with other kids
[Music]
[Music]